brittany faced the judge in a
conservatorship case and our lauren zema
is at the courthouse in the middle of
the free brittany drama
the conservative has got to go brittany
called into the hearing this afternoon
by phone and
it was explosive she testified against
her father jamie saying that he should
be punished
for the handling of her conservatorship
brittany also told the court that
members of her conservatorship were at
times emotionally abusive
the singer says the conservatorship has
left her feeling depressed
angry and alone her audio was played in
court and reporters were not allowed to
record
any of it but they were allowed to take
notes a source tells e.t brittany was
feeling confident and 100 percent ready
to address the court
her boyfriend sam askari posted this
photo
wearing a free britney t-shirt she has
told
the court she wants her voice heard so
how did all of this end up with brittany
asking to take the stand herself
in court well we're told quote britney
feels she is under a
constant microscope and she's been
painted in the worst
light the conservatorship's been in
place since 2008 after the singer's very
public struggle with her mental health
and there's been a renewed focus on the
conservatorship since the rise of the
free brittany movement
and the release of this new york times
documentary in february
the main thing that people became
fascinated with was her sort of
unraveling
the last known time britney attended a
hearing on her conservatorship was in
2019
she's never addressed the
conservatorship directly on social media
she has been open with her fans am i
okay
yes i'm totally fine i love freedom i
love independence
i'm taking a break right now because i'm
enjoying myself
britt shared images from her recent trip
to hawaii with her boyfriend
but some posts have been unusual she
repeated pics and shared endless dance
and catwalk videos
so could any of that hurt her case in
court
listen she's a pop star she's a singer
she tries to get attention for what
she's doing so i don't think any of
these things would necessarily hurt her
case
and there's another angle to today's
hearing is there a comeback at stake
will i ever take the stage again i have
no idea i'm having fun right now i'm a
transition in my life
and i'm enjoying myself britney has said
through her attorney
that she would not perform again as long
as her dad remains one of her
conservators
i think it wouldn't be surprising if her
father is removed if we slowly start to
see her taking the stage again and going
into the public eye
you